خمسة سلوكيات أقل شهرة لاضطراب فرط الحركة ونقص الانتباه مع رسومات
الشعار المبتكرة، دعنا نستمع أولاً إلى
نفس الأغنية بشكل متكرر حتى تكون قد
شاهدت مقاطع فيديو كهذه أو هذه،
فمن المحتمل أنك تجولت في
عالم اضطراب فرط الحركة ونقص الانتباه وتيك توك واضطراب فرط الحركة ونقص الانتباه أو
الاهتمام  يعد اضطراب نقص النشاط الزائد
أحد أكثر
اضطرابات النمو العصبي شيوعًا في
مرحلة الطفولة وفقًا لمركز السيطرة على الأمراض.
قد يكون الأشخاص المصابون باضطراب فرط الحركة ونقص الانتباه مفرطي النشاط أو لديهم
صعوبة في الانتباه أو التحكم في
السلوكيات المندفعة. الدكتور أنوني يونغ هو
طبيب نفسي سريري
بجامعة كولومبيا البريطانية ولديه
اهتمام خاص.  في اضطراب فرط الحركة ونقص الانتباه،
أصبح هو وزملاؤه مفتونين عندما
بدأوا في ملاحظة تدفق المرضى الذين
يطلبون المساعدة لتركيزهم وتركيزهم،
وكل ذلك تزامن، كما
يقول، مع تزايد شعبية
ما يسمى باضطراب فرط الحركة ونقص الانتباه تيك توك، وهو صغير جدًا
وفريقه شرع في البحث  فيما يتعلق بنوع
المعلومات التي تمت مشاركتها، وجدوا أن ما وجدوه
كان صادمًا أن أكثر من نصف
أفضل 100 مقطع فيديو شائع في ذلك الوقت
حول اضطراب فرط الحركة ونقص الانتباه تحتوي على
معلومات مضللة. أعتقد أن
المحادثة بأكملها حول الصحة العقلية
بالطبع قد تغيرت نحو الأفضل
بمعنى أن  الناس في الواقع
منفتحون وصادقون تمامًا في الحديث عن
صراعاتهم الفردية أريد أن
أعرف سبب بكائي ولكن التحدي أو
الجانب الآخر منه هو أنه
يصبح تقريبًا مصطلحًا يتم الحديث عنه في
المجال الشعبي أه حيث قد تكون المصطلحات السريرية
بدأ يُساء استخدامه، على سبيل المثال، كان هناك مقطع
فيديو يتحدث عن
ثبات الكائن في اضطراب فرط الحركة ونقص
الانتباه، تذكر كيف تحدثنا عن إصابتي باضطراب فرط الحركة ونقص الانتباه، لذا
لدي أيضًا مشكلات في ثبات الكائن، نعم،
إنه شيء بعيد عن الأنظار بعيدًا عن العقل،
مصطلح ثبات الكائن حقًا
لا علاقة له بثبات كائن اضطراب فرط الحركة ونقص الانتباه، إنه في
الحقيقة
مفهوم تنموي أساسي أكثر للأطفال
الرضع، وهو حقًا ما إذا كان
الأطفال يفهمون أن الناس ما زالوا
موجودين أم لا إذا لم تتمكن من رؤيتهم أو
سماعهم، فهناك مصطلح آخر شائع جدًا
استخدمت شيئًا يسمى مثل خلل
حساسية الرفض، نعم هل
تعلم أن 100٪ من الأشخاص المصابين باضطراب فرط الحركة ونقص الانتباه
يعانون من خلل حساسية الرفض
لأنه، وإذا
تعمقت حقًا في معرفة مصدر هذا
المصطلح، فهو مصطلح اقترحه
أحد الأطباء النفسيين ولكنه ليس مصطلحًا
مصطلح مقبول عالميًا وهو
بالتأكيد ليس مصطلحًا أه أود أن أقول إن
الغالبية العظمى من الأطباء النفسيين يستخدمون
مخاوف الشباب من أن
اتجاه التشخيص الذاتي للأشخاص الذين يعانون من اضطراب فرط الحركة ونقص
الانتباه يمكن أن يؤدي إلى مزيد من الوصمة
للحالة حوالي 10٪ من الأطفال
في  تم تشخيص إصابة الولايات المتحدة باضطراب فرط الحركة ونقص الانتباه، وتشير
تقديرات مركز السيطرة على الأمراض إلى أن هذا قد حدث
تاريخيًا في الماضي حيث كان الناس
يقولون أشياء أكثر شيوعًا مثل "أنا مصاب
بالوسواس القهري للغاية، أنا ثنائي القطب للغاية، أنا مصاب باضطراب فرط الحركة ونقص الانتباه" إذا
بدأ الجميع في تعريف أنفسهم
على أنهم مصابون باضطراب فرط الحركة ونقص الانتباه، فأنت تعرف إذا كان الأمر كذلك  10%
تصبح 20% تصبح 30 تصبح 50
تصبح 60% إذن ما هو
الاضطراب الذي نتحدث عنه هنا
أين نرسم الخط
[موسيقى]